all of the benchmarks for apple's brand
new m2 chip have just leaked all over
the internet we're talking about
geekbench cinebench gfx bench we got the
graphics everything included all of it
leaked this morning and to be honest i'm
actually surprised and impressed by the
performance because it's beating out
apple's own claims so with that said
let's jump right into the leaks first
off here's the headline report from mac
rumors leaked benchmarks confirm m2 chip
is up to 20 faster than the m1 and
surprisingly i was actually the first
one to show this off on twitter this
morning thanks to amos but before we get
into these leaked benchmarks i want to
mention that according to apple the m2
chip should be 18 faster in terms of
multi-core performance so just remember
that because these leaks are impressive
and here it is the first benchmark leak
for the m2 chip we have
1919 points for single core and 8
928 points for multi-core which is
better than i personally estimated
around five months ago when i made the
m2 performance estimation video but
before i show you guys just how much
faster that is compared to the m1 chip i
want to go down into the system
information and point out the base
frequency we have 3.49
gigahertz which is actually quite a bit
faster than the previous m1 which was
sitting at 3.2 gigahertz so that means
the clock speeds are sitting at around
11
higher than the m2 chip and keep in mind
that this model does have
the 16 gigs of ram so it's not 24 which
the 24 model could actually score higher
than this but going over to the
geekbench browser we can see that the
best score for the m1 ship was 1720
in terms of single core and in terms of
the multi-core we got
7474
in terms of the multi-core so that
basically translates over to
11.56 percent better for the single core
performance as you can see in this chart
and then 19.45
better performance in terms of the
multi-core which is better than my
estimates because i personally estimated
around 9.3 for single core and then 18
for the multi-core so it seems like it's
doing better than apple showed off or
claimed and if you're wondering just how
fast that number is in terms of the
single core performance
1919 keep in mind that the best
mainstream consumer chip from intel
their i9 12 900k and the kf they are the
only ones that scored better than this
brand new low power usage consumer level
m2 chip look at that 1947 in 1990
compared to 1919 but wait it gets better
because there was another leak score
1927
even better for the m2 chip now i know a
lot of you guys are going to say that
it's geekbench and it doesn't really
show the real world performance or the
performance under an actual workload
well thankfully the cinema scores leaked
as well as you can see right here in
terms of the single core we have a
thousand seven hundred and thirty eight
compared to eight thousand seven hundred
794 for the actual multi-thread or
multi-core in cinebench which basically
makes the single core thread performance
13.5
faster which is actually very very
impressive however the multi-core is
only 11.6
faster than the m1 chip in terms of
cinebench r23 which is a little bit
disappointing but keep in mind that
cinebench is still not fully optimized
for apple silicon yes it runs on metal
they got it to work on metal instead of
actually working through rosetta but it
still uses ombre i think it's called so
it's still kind of tuned for x86 chips
and not for apple silicon but now with
that said let's move over to the
graphics performance which apple says
the m2 chip is 35
faster than the m1 but you have to make
a distinction here because the m2 chip
actually has two more gpu cores it has
10 instead of eight with the m1 so
that's 25
more cores so with that said we should
have expected 25 extra performance right
out of the gate but apple is showing off
35 percent which means around 10 more
from the actual ipc improvements
themselves which i thought was a little
bit disappointing but check out these
new gpu leaks in geekbench metal 29
832
which is actually higher than my initial
estimate five months ago with 28
874 which basically makes the
performance improvement 41
faster with the m2 compared to the m1
which is actually pretty good but wait
it gets even better than that because on
wcf tech they actually found another
leak for the gpu performance which is
even better 30
627
points with the new m2 10 core gpu that
basically means that with this new leak
score the m2 is now 45
faster than the m1 and that is what i
call an impressive improvement but keep
in mind that's the 10 core version
within the m2 macbook pro with the fan
so likely the macbook air is going to be
quite a bit slower in terms of the 10
core because of throttling maybe it
might be around i don't know a few
percentage points slower than that and
also you have to keep in mind that the
macbook air is going to come with the 8
core gpu at the base price so if we
consider the performance of the 8 core
it should be around 25
400 which is still a pretty impressive
improvement compared to the 21 000 that
you get with the m1 and once again i
know a lot of you guys don't like
geekbench especially in terms of the
metal performance so thankfully we also
got some leaks with gfx bench as well as
you can see right here we have some new
scores for the m2 chip and i've put up a
comparison with the m1 now in aztec
ruins normal tier we have
295.6 fps compared to 203 fps with the
m1 which is
45.6 faster which almost perfectly
matches the score that we got with
geekbench so this is pretty reliable and
i'm actually excited because i was not
expecting that much of a performance
improvement now moving on to aztec ruins
high tier 109.9 fps compared to 77.4
which is 42 faster than the 1440p
manhattan 3.1.1
off screen 175.8 compared to 122.3
which is
43.7
faster so it's staying pretty consistent
but then in car chase for some reason it
slows down 229.8 compared to 173.2
which is only 32.7
faster but still i'd say that this is
pretty impressive and i like to use
aztec ruins because i think that's the
most reliable and the highest and test
so wow
there you go that is incredibly
impressive for the gpu and i've got to
take some of my words back because i was
going off of apple's claims and they
were drastically underestimating their
own gpu so this is really good to see
that the real
performance leaked benchmarks are coming
out now and confirming that it's faster
than we expected so with that said
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did let me know your comments down
below and click the circle button to
subscribe because we are going to be
ordering that new m2 macbook pro this
friday and we're going to be testing
everything with that new macbook pro so
definitely do that and check out one of
those two right there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]